oh how the mighty have fallen so this
movie I was nervous going into reign of
the supermen for a number of reasons one
is the ongoing spot enos of the track
record for DC animated films but I also
had a reason to be hopeful because not
only was the Death of Superman quite
good it was actually great
they made my top 10 films the last year
it was excellent and i'm even that big a
fan of The Death of Superman storyline
I'm also not a fan of the reign of
Superman's storyline but you know coming
off the back of that I had some degree
of hope and boy that hope just got
squashed I mean I was nervous anyway
because I mean it's got the same
director as Death of Superman
I know a lot of people ascribe a lot of
power to the director and they're like
oh so we'll be just as good well no
because Sam Sam I think is Delisle is
how he pronounces that last name he he
is a good animation director but
ultimately he can't elevate a script he
has made very good movies for DC
Animated he has made very bad movies for
DC Animated and he really is only as
good as the script he has and in the
case of death of Superman he was working
up a very good script and the case of
this which was not written by the same
screenwriters who were involved as Death
of Superman this is not a good script
now to be fair I think they're actually
also working off of a material that's
harder to adapt while I said flat-out I
didn't really like the original comic
book story of the death of Superman or
the reign of the super
and at least death of Superman is simple
it's a very straightforward story
monster shows up Superman fights it both
die that's the story so what that meant
was that film and the reason that film
was so good was because it zeroed in on
what mattered making Superman making us
understand why Superman is important why
he matters to people and the impact on
those around him when he dies and
accomplish both of those things better
than the comic book version did and as a
result was a really good film reign of
the Superman is not a simple story
because it is a story of four characters
who show up and claim to either be
Superman in some way or claim a right to
his mantle in some way shape or form
none of these are characters that in the
again I'm talking mostly about the movie
here none of these are characters who we
have seen or been dealing with before
and in the characters that we have
carrying over are just always playing
catch-up with what the heck it is that's
going on so oh god what do I started
this thing I if you follow me on Twitter
this was the movie that last week I give
like if I'm accounting for when the
video will go up last week or whatever
this this was the movie I alluded to
where the sequel was such a drop off
from from the movie that came before
that it drove me to drink to get through
the movie because I I was in pain very
early into this film so this film has
like I could I could teach a film
writing course on how not to write
exposition and just you and just show
people this film this is some of the
worst clunkiest exposition that I can
remember seeing in a long time
and this is a story that requires a lot
of ex
position there is so much that needs to
explain about all four of these
characters who show up and it's just so
bad at it one of the laziest easy go-to
tricks for a film to get some exposition
across is a news cast
whether it be here's a story about a
thing that happened or you can do it as
a debate panel between you know a couple
of characters jet you know to get the
audience up to speed I'm not saying I'm
not saying it never works but it's a
crutch it's a cliche it's a very it
it's an exposition dump that's exactly
what it is it can work but it's a it's a
go to standard exposition now not only
does this film open with a newscast
debate between two characters to
establish that these new super men are
around and how some people feel about
them and how long it's been and all this
other logistical stuff the next scene
immediately is set in the newsroom as
Perry White is assigning news stories
which is barely just barely removed from
being the exact same kind of exposition
dump and it's serving the same purpose
again as this time we just see him lay
out how it's affected the world in
general whereas the last characters
would dumping us exposition about the
new Superman now we're getting world
exposition getting dumped in us to
season all my god
and it doesn't get better none of it
gets better characters the way
characters establish how they know each
other because most of these characters
do have some pre-existing relationship
but we don't know that because it wasn't
shown in the previous film and it's just
so awkwardly inserted every time the
writing of this thing is atrocious it
gave me up frigging headache I'm I'm
genuinely pissed off at this movie at
this point because it is such a drop
from the previous one plus also it
retains the basically one and only
wah that I had with deaths of Superman
which is this version of Lex Luthor who
is unintimidating and whiney I haven't
really talked about the the supermen
that are in this so why don't we bring
up these doofuses so not enough time is
spent with any one of them for them to
feel like a character that we can even
care about much less root for honestly
the film more than anybody is probably
mostly about Lois Lane which in theory
is an angle that could work because you
know she's the character who knew Clark
knew Superman and you can filter through
her lens to to simplify the story a bit
but we're asked by the movie to invest
in these four supposed supermen and you
can't you just get first of all the
super boy who is insufferable he falls
into the classic error of the writers
tried to deliberately make him
irritating to other characters but
that's a really hard thing to do without
also making him irritating to the
audience and he was really really
irritating and then we've got Steele who
is just kind of there cool well he's a
good guy that's it like I couldn't tell
you it based off this based off this
film how he's portrayed in this film I
could not tell you anything about him
other than he made his suit himself and
he's our good guy yay there's the
Eradicator who is played is a little bit
more mysterious which could have worked
if they played up the possibility of him
quite likely being the actual Superman
or at least most closely related to him
but they don't play up that mystery just
kind of shows up and gives a wooden
delivery intermittently and then goes
away again and then finally there's
cyborg superman which sport
and yeah I'm just gonna talk spoilers
about this thing cuz it's stupid and if
I spoil it for you you don't have to
watch it
spoilers cyborg super means the bad guy
which honestly if you know anything
about the comics isn't a surprise
anyways because you know that's like
that that's like trying to hide that
Harvey Dent's gonna become two-face at
this point if you know anything about
the comics thing you know a that this is
Hank Henshaw who actually we did see in
the previous film in one of the one of a
decent moments and I thought had some
decent setup except they screw up his
motivation - I'll get to that
so we've we know it's hank henshaw and
we know that he is the bad guy and his
whole angle is not uninteresting but he
is he does such a bad job of making it
believable that people didn't
immediately go really that's Superman
because he's acting wonky and like
people eventually do court nod to that
but like some of the stuff that gets
pulled
I'm like really bailing the world at
large let that get this far seriously
and okay so huh and hank henshaw they
bring in they bring in Darkseid into
this and I don't know why but I
seriously I have no clue why Darkseid is
somehow dragged into this and tied up
with hank henshaw there's absolutely no
reason hank henshaw is motivation for
wanting revenge on Superman and wanting
to tarnish his name does in no way
require Darkseid zip zero zilch and
don't get me called ahead to account for
how we got the cipher but no I didn't
know anything it's comic books make
something up like first of all you tease
Darkseid and guess who never actually
shows up it has to be fun
directly in this dark side you tease him
and he never shows up I mean he shows up
on screen does he show up on earth there
was anybody have to fight him no not
that that would have saved the thing
because it probably
would have been a repeat of Justice
League war which was boring as hell and
that dark side is boring as hell because
he was just an end boss you can't tease
the return of a guy that I wish I hadn't
even bothered seeing the last movie he
appeared in I'm not getting this upset
by a film in a little while Oh Justice
League the way the Justice League is
removed from this narrative so that they
can't fix the problem which I
acknowledge was probably a good thing to
do because otherwise you have to wonder
why are they dealing with this the way
in which it's done is the stupidest
thing I have seen in ages basically
parademons showed that like we get a
portal in the sky and parademon show up
and they fight them and the portal thing
like loses stability and Falls and lands
on the Justice League and they get
transported elsewhere and then it also
dissolves on impact so like they're
standing here at Falls Putin they get
transported off and then it's gone it
was already falling when some of the
members of the Justice League got into
position so that every single one of
them was underneath this thing it's the
flash the flash the flash just stood
there and like some of them weren't even
work even gonna be hit by this thing and
they walked and we're like uh-huh oh my
god I swore at this movie a lot I man
this thing is such a mess
and it is a mess out of incompetence
because some of these some of the DC
animated movies that have been a mess
because this is far from the first one
have been a mess because they tried to
tackle too much in one story sometimes
they're a mess because the very idea
that they were trying to tackle just is
too complicated doesn't adapt well and
you could argue that this is a difficult
story to adapt to actually even grant
that but the mistakes made at the
scripting level that resulted in this
are so basic like screenwriting 101
did this not get a Polish like this
debate this feels like a rough draft of
a script this feels like the first pass
were you okay roughly this like gets us
from beginning to middle and how do we
tighten this how do we polish this how
do we make it more fun and less
mechanical because that's the plot
exists purely mechanically nothing feels
motivated by characters it's just the
gears of the plot just mechanically
twisting oh god this was awful and it
made worse for how good Death of
Superman was so personally I'm gonna
choose to believe that death of Superman
is a standalone film and Superman never
comes back because yeah they do the
Superman comes back and think I'm a
freakin mullet that everybody makes fun
oh why what that's a punch line the fact
that he came back in an all-black suit
wielding guns and had a mullet is a
punch line now Oh
I'm gonna give myself an aneurysm okay I
gotta stop it sucks rate of the supermen
did you see it I am so sorry if you did
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down to
comments let's talk about it hope it's
something you can do buttons links
support me on the patreon because I need
to be able to afford more booze if I'm
gonna be watching stuff like this
there's nothing eise to check out to the
side give them a look it's also okay if
you don't cuz at the end of the day
folks you're the council I just run the
meetings and sometimes I watch this crap
so that you don't have to and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]